So peppermint is a flavor that's big during the holidays, pretty much every year.
We're creating a bigger statement with it this year.
It kind of cues the season so we're hoping it will get the guest excited about the holidays.
And one thing about peppermint that really has going for is its great color and great shape.
It can be pink, it can be fun red tones.
Even when it's white, it's really sort of wintery and neat.
And then it also brings a lot of texture I feel...
...like when you do some crumbling of the candies like on the cookies here.
To me, that really is a feast for the eyes...
...which I think is a part of the reason peppermint is just bigger than ever.